Robert Stirling molecular biophysics and
biochemistry and senior research
scientist in diagnostic radiology and
this is in recognition of his roles as a
founding a fellow of Whitney are now
and also lettuces in general this
enthusiastic unwavering support for the
integration science and humanities I'll
also add that this lecture series is
held in conjunction with a seminar
habits of the line which is taught by
myself by a smart gambler professor of
philosophy and Dean of the faculty of
arts sciences I'll also say that because
this is integrative science and
humanities I'm a scientist I'm
particularly delighted by this PhD here
at Yale and went on to do a postdoc
never mind it's not a professor
person is a social psychologist he works
on a range of topics including the
emotional political typology and moral
psychology his worth is extremely
interesting its distinguished by an
interest both in deep theoretical
questions often informed by philosophy
as well as some extremely clever and
repellent experimental research there is
a fight engaged assistant scientist in
studies that is also any evidence in
this personality and as a reputation is
one the most imaginative and simply
incidentally kindest most fun
psychologists around who that explains
part of what's going on with us and
sanding the multi credit David works on
both as both a research scientist who is
also a noted public intellectual need is
a tremendously popular intro psych
course a thousand students he's
published on heads and their times given
a TED Talks and he's also wrong he also
participates in a podcast with Worcester
cameras original very back wizards you
can vary that wizards is the only thing
on the web that's really worthwhile
incredibly interesting and rather
unnerving out of an accession of
philosophical psychological issues it is
only philosophy podcast that begins
warning that you have seen it was
graduated in areas not my register he
was that Peter salivate I had some
credit for his research directions he
told me that his research on the set
some of which we'll talk about today was
sparked by seven are around
I do not study morality when I met Dave
my interests more how to be moral
psychology was driven by his influence
and in fact my very first a permit topic
was one that we had also I'm very much
an asset even in graduate school David
had a reputation as a force of nature
and found
well that my name is Carl azuz and we
continued to marvel at especially so
he's talking today an understanding
moral lines
you know you're not supposed to almost
cry when you come to give a talk your
alma mater but I can only say that Paul
is far too generous in his introduction
it is my deep pleasure to be invited
here and and as I told him right before
I came up first of all I was your
students I know you're trying to
distance yourself but if it weren't for
Paul I simply just would not be an
academic and that's that's the most
efficient way I can communicate what
what his influence has been on me and I
have to say that Professor Gendler Tamar
was at Cornell as a philosopher when I
got hired and between the two of them I
think I probably if there is a
counterfactual world in which they don't
exist I don't know what I would be doing
but it would involve you know minimum
wage jobs which is fine
it would just be different okay so it's
really my deep pleasure to be here and
yes presidents eleve was my real advisor
credit I want to talk a little bit about
it and one of the reasons it's such an
honor to be here is because it really is
the case that my interests have always
straddled sort of philosophy and
psychology and to the extent that I was
allowed to be interested in the
humanities in grad school it's become a
little more popular now to do something
like read philosophy when you're a
psychologist but I used to get mocked by
my fellow psychologists not by Paul but
by other social psychologists chanting
you're a philosopher which only meant
that they didn't think I was in the lab
enough so what I want to talk about
though is Paul said my interest was
first sparked in the topic of disgust
from his seminar he made us read
something on the topic and it's been a
ten years I think since we and much of
this work has been done in collaboration
with Paul and it's been on essentially
one of my interests is the overlap
between emotions and moral and ethical
judgment I want to point out though that
a lot is sad in fact for those of you
who are in the seminar you will have
read hopefully one of the papers on the
role of emotions and moral judgment a
lot of work has been done in the last
fifteen or so years in general and
emotion in the last thirty years there's
been an explosion of research on the
topic of how emotions influence our
judgments but this is not a new idea in
fact if you read Aristotle is one of my
favorite quotes because it really
captures a lot of the work that that has
been done in the last as I said thirty
or so years on the role of emotion and
judgment so Aristotle says the emotions
are all those feelings that so change
menace to affect their judgment such
your anger pity fear and the like with
their opposites take for instance the
emotion of anger here we must discover
what the state of mind of angry people
is who the people are with whom they
usually get angry and on what grounds
they get angry with them it is not
enough to know one or even two of these
points the same is true of the other
emotions so that insight has only
recently really you know when talking
about the history of intellectual
thought been started to be empirically
explored and my specific interest has
been in one of these emotions so while
it may be obvious that emotions are a
deep part of lots of social judgments in
a particular moral and ethical judgments
I think Aristotle's point here is one to
take seriously that emotions are not all
the same and to understand how various
specific emotions might influence our
judgment in specific ways has been one
of the things that has kept my interest
in the last fifteen or so years I'll
start with this human beings have a
unique problem well it's not unique lots
of animals have the same problem and
that problem is we have bodies
one of the problems with having a body
and not being a little spirit that
floats around at least I think is that
we need to protect them so you know we
don't want them to be injured but one of
the problems with having a body is that
they can get sick so we have this
problem of trying to fight off things
like parasites because they would kill
us so the environment poses this problem
we have to have some way of keeping
ourselves from an infection and
contamination now we're we're okay at
this now so we do things like we know we
got to wash our hands all the time in
order to prevent the spread of disease
we spend billions of dollars a year on
different kinds of cleaning products
which roll by the way the same I mean
you could use the same thing to clean
your hair and the sink and your body but
we need specific hair cleaner sink
cleaner and and body cleaners we're
really motivated in finding ways to
protect ourselves from this sort of
contamination well in the one hand that
if we if we had to rely on our explicit
beliefs about how to protect ourselves
we wouldn't do very well so we in fact
have an immune system so once we get
infected the reason that we don't die so
easily is that we have a dedicated
system that attacks pathogens we know
the importance of this from people like
David better also known as the bubble
boy who are born without immune systems
and so this is it
you don't live very long but as many
psychologists have pointed out there's a
line of defense before your regular
immune system kicks in and they've often
referred to this as the behavioural
immune system the behavioural immune
system is just a term used to describe
that those collect that collection of
motivations that keeps us away from
things that might give us disease or
contaminate us one of the things that
provides a motivation to stay away from
disease is an emotion that we label
disgust so discuss there you can see the
characteristic facial expression the
wrinkled nose the raising of
these lip muscles William Ian Miller who
wrote this wonderful book actually I
think we read part of it in in Paul's
seminar when I was a grad student gives
a good a definition as any about the
emotion of disgust a sense of a version
of something perceived as dangerous
because of its powers to contaminate in
fact or pollute by proximity contact or
ingestion is you introspective access
can tell you that you get grossed out
when things that may be potentially
contaminating are close to you right so
many have argued that the origins of
this is in just distaste so most other
animals don't have the sort of full blow
and disgust that we have but once
something is in their mouth they might
be motivated to expel it the same can be
said of very young children so infants
when you put something bitter or sour in
their mouth which is extraordinarily fun
you can put some quinine a few drops and
you'll see that they make you it's you
know something caused permanent damage
they make this face that's that's the
same face that we make when we are
disgusted so if you put something that
tastes bad in our mouth we make that
face but right around when we turn six
or seven years old we start making that
face or perhaps a little earlier we
start making that face when you just
show us a picture of something gross so
one of the I have to be honest that one
of the reasons I started studying
disgust was because it's it's easy to
study so one of the things that makes it
very easy to study is it's one of the
easiest emotions to induce so you bring
it if you want to study anger or sadness
you can bring people into the laboratory
and Peter salivate has done a lot of
this work or you can induce an emotion
you can make people feel sad or anger by
showing them a film clip or something
but you know it's not really the same
kind of anger that they might feel in
real life so you're just trying to
approximate it disgust on the other hand
sometimes all it takes is a word to
actually get the full blow and disgust
and some people are actually so
sensitive you can make them gag by just
saying words there is no contaminant
around there's no odor
but they will be easily disgusted I you
know I true so I'm just gonna show you
it's not really that disgust I'm just
gonna show you one photo but just if
you're here this is I was laughing
actually because part of part of what I
had to do for a Coursera course where I
was invited to give a guest talk was
only use images that might be properly
accredited Creative Commons lists so I
had to I give I don't know who Paul
Joseph is but he to me he will always be
famous for taking a picture of poop okay
thank you because I was not going to pay
for one of the things that that is a
feature of disgust is that there seems
to be a rigid sort of universal set of
listeners that is when you look across
cultures there are a set of things that
that tend to discuss people so some of
these as the psychologist Paul Rose and
point out these tend to be bodily fluids
feces urine blood vomit run flesh pus
just our disease appearance these are
things that are associated with
contamination and disease so it's a it's
a good thing that we avoid these these
bodily fluids now I here's what I have
to say it's it's not as if there aren't
also a ton of differences across
cultures so all you need to think about
is you know if you were raised in China
for instance you would find some of the
food that we here to be very disgusting
and vice versa
so there is a lot of room for input into
what becomes disgusting but nonetheless
it is interesting that you have such
universal sort of no matter where you
look these things tend to discuss people
so one of the features of disgust that
makes it particularly powerful is that
unlike other emotions it works it works
on the principle of contagion or
contamination so if you are if you touch
something that is disgusting you can
easily become disgusting it's not the
same for other emotion
like anger for instance right if if
somebody if you are stand if Paul makes
me angry and you're standing next to him
or you're talking to him
you can sorry I won't get angry at you
unless there's actual an appraisal that
is made that you have done something to
make me angry
disgust seems to bypass that appraisal
process in fact many people prefer to
call it a reflex because of this they
think it's different from other social
emotions because of how easily it can
spread from you know elicitor to elicit
all right so touch something disgusting
you become disgusting it's particularly
interesting because this is exactly what
you would want an emotion to do if that
emotions job is to protect you from
disease so far before we had any sort of
disease theory you know and any germ
theory of disease discussed was tracking
things by contamination and so you know
before we could do things like slow down
this is just gross
slow down you know take a picture where
you can actually see what happens when
you sneeze you might have actually been
disgusted by snot which is a good thing
so it's powerful because easy to elicit
it works by the process of contamination
which is good if what you want to do is
protect yourself against disease it also
because of these two features it
influences a whole set a wide set of
judgments that is if you you can free
this is just a specific case of economic
judgment you will devalue something so
there is a robust binding and behavioral
economics that you tend to value your
own possessions more in this sort of a
rational way so the very very same thing
that somebody else has like a mug if you
are just told that it's yours you tend
to over value it but if you're made to
feel disgust in an incidental way you
actually devalue your possessions so
there is something about disgust that
makes it a powerful influence on a wide
set of judgments so when you're asked
how much your mug is worth if you've
been made to feel disgust you actually
undervalue it which goes it's the
complete opposite of the general finding
of overvalued obsessions but disgust
also seems to have a particular
relationship with a certain kind of
social judgment and the philosopher
Martha knows
has pointed this out thus throughout
history certain discussed properties sly
meanness bad smell stickiness 2kf
elements have repeatedly a monotonous
lead been associated with Jews women
homosexuals Untouchables lower-class
people
all of those are imagined as tainted by
the dirt of the body so this is again an
insight that many people have had that
disgust seems to play a particularly
powerful and important role in our
opinions of certain kinds of individuals
or social groups this is this is
actually from the very first talk I gave
as a it's a young graduate student in
the psychology part I was so so nervous
but the night before I was looking up
World War 2 propaganda and I found this
Nazi children's book this says just look
at these guys the louse infested beards
the filthy protruding ears the stained
fatty clothes Jews often have an
unpleasant Swedish odour if you have a
good knowledge against ologies so in the
Nussbaum Code and in this I want to
point something out that it is
specifically these low-level features of
disgust that is that the sly meanness
the decay the smell the thalamus those
can be tagged to a particular individual
or social group or sometimes in action
and by that tag become negatively
evaluated there is a difference between
that and saying well I'm disgusted by a
moral act so for instance people often
say I'm disgusted by a used-car salesman
who takes care - who takes advantage of
an elderly consumer there it's sort of
the moral evaluation that you're
reporting your repelled by but in these
cases what it really is is a you are
given a low-level characteristic of that
usually elicits disgust and you tag an
entire social group so it becomes a
powerful rhetorical tool to tell
somebody you know this person they they
really they're dirty they smell bad
because of the ease with which it's
elicited in the process of sort of
contagion contamination we can really
tag individuals and social groups with
the power of the disgust emotion this
has been done more recently by
individuals who try to convince others
that homosexuality is bad
wrong so this is from a website that it
I don't recommend that you look up but
the the language here is very similar to
language that has been used as no spawn
points out for for women for Jews and in
the past gays are worthy of death for
their vile sex practices they're like
dogs eating their own vomit and sows
wallowing in their own feces what we
were originally interested in was if
this is true if it is the case that
disgust really is such a powerful social
tool and a powerful tool in in the
rhetoric the moral rhetoric and
political rhetoric then we might expect
to see a certain kind of relationship
between disgust and moral judgments so
that's what I want to talk to you about
today specifically two source of
evidence that disgust is does seem to
have a special relationship to a certain
kind of social political moral judgment
so first let's talk about individual
differences in disgust and then I'll
talk about experimental manipulations of
disgust where we can better find the
causal relationship between emotion of
disgust and Rajas but what we started
with was an individual difference in
disgust so the thinking was if disgust
really has this relationship with
certain kinds of moral social political
evaluations what we might expect is that
people who are naturally higher are
naturally easy more easily grossed out
ought to be more easily convinced by
things like those rhetorical messages
that I showed you all right so it is if
you're easily disgusted maybe if I tell
you that a group is disgusting you'll be
more likely to be convinced so what we
would expect to find is a relationship
between certain moral judgments and just
the degree to which you're easily
grossed out lucky for us there was
already some work done on individual
differences in disgust so there is a
measure called the disgust sensitivity
questionnaire there's actually a few
individual differences of disgust now
and they tend to find the same thing all
this does is divide the world up into
people who are more easily disgusted and
people who are less easily disgusted so
if I gave you the scale right now
you know there would be a distribution
in the room that's that just like any
other motion we would have a bunch of
individual livers that some people are
high in anxiety some people are more
easily angered some people are very
easily disgusted so if the scale does it
simply asks a bunch of questions here's
some two examples even if I were hungry
I would not drink a bowl of my favorite
soup if had been stirred by used but
thoroughly washed flyswatter to what
extent do you agree or disagree or a
question like while you were walking
through a tunnel on a railroad track you
smell urine would you be very disgust or
not all disgusted I I always try to
admit from the get-go
I am very easily disgusted I score high
on the scale in fact it is it was always
my goal to never actually run the
studies when I got to Cornell a graduate
student
Yoel in Barre ran all the studies
because I could not look at those images
so I used I used the same images over
and over again because or else I get
lightheaded so the the nice thing about
this is and other people have done the
work is that your responses on this
scale predict your actual behavior so
you might expect you would hope that if
this is a valid scale what you would
find is if you report that you're very
easily disgusted you also wouldn't do
things like touch something gross sure
enough you bring people into the lab you
know if you ask them to these are meal
worms I gave a talk at in Ithaca and as
part of the talk of it got mealworms and
distributed them just to see who would
eat them I'm a vegetarian so on moral
grounds
I still wear shoes made out of mealworm
leather but you know other people killed
them either so so it predicts actual
behavior there are other reasons to
think that these scales are actually
picking up on on emotional reactions so
actually as when I was a postdoc we
started doing these studies so we got
the disgust sensitivity questionnaire
this was actually in collaboration with
Paul and we came up with some measure of
well judge
that we had made up and I was working
with another person at UC Irvine pedido
who was interested in political judgment
and he said well if you're gonna be
running studies with you know you're not
my adviser I guess but my friend my
former professor at Yale he's like I'm
paying your postdoc at least you could
do is toss in some questions for me
throw me a bone so I did and I inserted
as a favor just simple political
orientation items and our moral judgment
measure we just weren't getting what we
thought we would get but what I kept
getting what we kept getting was a
relationship between self-reported
political orientation and disgust
sensitivity such that I ran this study
two or three times and we would get this
relationship such that people who were
more conservative reported they were
more easily disgusted now I did I don't
want to have anything to do with this
you might imagine that it's not
something that you know it's like it's
like doing work on atheism yeah
somebody's gonna hate you so I avoided
it it wasn't until I got to Cornell when
you LM bar who's a graduate student at
the time said you know we really have to
investigate this you know like what's
going on here and we did so across a
number of studies three different
populations we documented disaffected
we've replicated a number of times
whenever we've looked it's actually
they're the more likely people are to
say that they're conservative the more
likely they are to be easily disgusted
and I have to point out that I could
save this the opposite way the more
likely they are to be liberal less less
easily discuss that they are so with
Eric Houser was a grad student at
Cornell as well we we named our one of
our papers dirty liberals to try to you
know not be biased so there was
something to be said about describing
the relationship in that way so I what
finally really convinced me that we had
an effect here was this we were able to
collect data across the country and to
replicate this so
simply higher numbers here indicate that
you're more easily disgusted and the
more you go to the right of the graph
them it's your report that you're very
conservative one of the first things
you'll notice is if you carry the error
bars for the liberal are much smaller
that all that means is that there are
many more liberals go online to fill out
a questionnaire about moral judgment
it's a it's it's true but but you know
there are a variety of ways we ensured
that that you know if you randomly grab
equivalent numbers of conservatives and
liberals the effect is still there the
other thing I want to point out is this
effect is very modest all right so this
is actually one of those cheater plots
it should be zero to four and so this is
demonstrating that the effect is there
but if what you want to do is predict
political orientation measuring disgust
is not the most efficient thing to do
you should probably just ask people
their political orientation even if you
ask them what state they live in you
have a better you have a better
predictor but nonetheless things were of
theoretical interest to us and it's how
the relationship was robust we actually
did in the same paper we demonstrated
that that if you actually looked
state-by-state at disgust sensitivity
scores this was correlated with the
margin of victory of Obama over McCain
and the Oh a presidential election which
is just another way of collecting the
same data but this seemed sexier
I mean political cuz like self report
also predicts voting so you can imagine
it but somehow you know reviewers really
wanted okay I the other thing we found
is when you look across the world we
found a very similar relationship no
matter where we look so what we're
plotting here is this the simple
correlation you know 1.0 it would be a
perfect relationship between the two
variables and this is just the
relationship between political
orientation higher numbers indicate
conservatism and disgust sensitivity
higher numbers indicate you're more
easily grossed out no matter where you
look across the world you get a very
similar result so one of the
first questions was well are there
particular issues that seem especially
related to this emotional tendency is
what features a conservatism are we
looking at that are associated with
political I mean with disgust
sensitivity no matter again where we
look there were two that popped out so
we we actually created a sort of at
Cornell we just got a bunch of
hot-button political issues we asked
people what was important that
politically and over and over again we
saw that the biggest relationships were
with two issues gay marriage and
abortion that's not to say that there
aren't other issues that might be
related but of the ones that we measured
we would always get B's we followed up
on this and we found that not only was
it the case that people's opposition in
gay marriage and abortion their explicit
judgments on these things were predicted
by their disgust sensitivity but their
implicit judgments that is if you use
some techniques and social psychologists
have developed to measure attitudes that
people aren't willing to report so in
this case we use a couple of different
measures like the implicit association
test was one of them this is actually an
explicit the relationship with implicit
is the same implicit attitudes just the
higher more easily discussing you are
the more likely we are to oppose gay
marriage the abortion plot looks almost
exactly the same so here what you'll see
is that higher numbers here indicate
opposition and gay marriage males are
more likely to report that they're
opposed to gay marriage then then
females in our sample but the
relationship between discussed is the
same so explanations implicit attitudes
all should very similar a [ __ ] other
labs have since then replicated
conceptually at least some of these
findings so if you're concerned at all
that a self-report measure of an
emotional tendency like how grossed out
you are
might not capture the real emotional
reaction others have used physiological
measures so what they do here is they
simply this is not a real picture from
the study it's just a funny picture it's
like a lie-detector test but if I were
to show you some disgusting pictures and
simply get some physiological measures
what you find is that some of you are
more aroused to these disgusting images
than others and it turns out that this
is also correlated with attitudes
especially toward homosexuality it is
the more grossed-out you are by by
pictures of disgust and specifically not
sexual pictures I'm just grossed out by
a variety of images that make you
disgusted then more like you are to be
politically opposed to gay marriage so
and again using other scales using
physiological measures the same
relationship has been shown now of
course it's a concern with everything
that I've just told you that this has
been only correlational data so the
other step to understand the
relationship between this this emotional
response and moral social political
judgment is to actually bring people
into the lab and manipulate it to see if
it causes shifts and what people think
even if they're temporary shifts then
even if they're small shifts what people
have found over and over again
a variety of ways to do something like
induced disgust so the use of a foul
odor a bitter taste there's this
Trainspotting clip that's particularly
disgusting you can just type in the
dirtiest toilet in Scotland I think is
to youtube if you're interested this is
a using a posthypnotic suggestion to
instruct people to feel a flasher
disgust sorry to give you a warning for
this gross the wound I have a friend
who's a dermatologist actually and she
gave me access to to a bunch so I got
some database of skin conditions and
yeah you could just be entertained for
days but then but then if you get even
the slightest of rashes you
you'll go crazy this is a study that was
actually done not by us but this using
your bitter taste the philosopher Jessie
Prince they were interested in the
relationship between distastes again as
I've told you many of argue that the
origins of the disgust reaction is from
this basic distaste reaction that
expelling expelling a foul substance for
your mouth to protect yourself against
poison they gave individuals a sweet
drink water or a bitter drink and they
asked them to make moral judgments about
a variety of scenarios so in this case
this is just one example Tim is a
graduate student he likes to have
library books um to help him with his
research library won't allow him to
check out any more books since he has so
many overdue so we started to simply
leave with the books from the library
without checking them out so he asked on
a scale of 0 to 100 how wrong is this
and what you find is I always have to
tell people like this is these are not
my graphs because I would never the
precision with which you can plot
effects using bottles it's a little
disappointing but Jesse Prinz
is very into pretty pictures but
hopefully you can see that the effect is
there people are actually harsher the
reason that I point to this study in
particular was because they had a nice
finding within this study that they
didn't predict but which they had they
bothered to read our papers I'm at a
predicted that this effect actually only
held for conservatives that is it was
political conservatives who seemed to be
influenced in their moral judgment so
this harshness effect emerge but not for
the Liberals so there had actually been
now there's been quite a bit of work
showing that disgust seems to influence
moral and social attitudes what we were
interested in though was whether or not
this held for in general moral attitudes
as some have argued or their specific
effects so as I started to talk by
arguing that busy that disgust might
have a specific role in protecting us
against contamination and disease if
this were the case then we would expect
some have argued that
disgust would especially influenced
judgments of certain social groups or
individuals or actions that were
particularly associated with a kind of
thing that could spread disease so
sexual behaviors behaviors involving
cleanliness or certain differences in
the kind of food you eat those kinds of
things would be the ones that you would
expect to be associated with disgust we
did again with ul and Paul we use a foul
odor in this case it's um it's almost as
if we were vying for the ignoble prize
we use fart spray which is the thing is
we didn't invent that use of fart spray
and the study of disgust but you know we
we definitely were carrying the
tradition on its so the way that it
worked was half of the time we bring
people into the lab and we just asked
them to rate their attitudes in this
case we use a scale called a feeling
thermometer these are standardized
scores where you just say you know
people can feel very coldly or very
warmly to social groups how do you feel
about and then we would ask them a
variety of groups I'm only showing you a
few groups so this these are ratings of
African Americans the elderly lesbian
women and gay men and so half of the
time we were just bring him in on a day
when the lab didn't smell half of the
time we actually would spray the room
with this foul odor you just use just
spray it in the corner and well you know
one of the problems with this method
though is the research assistants get
used to the smell so disgust I mean
sorry odor is one of those things that
you have [ __ ] weight very very quickly
so your neurons stop firing after a
while so they would it's this is why
people spray too much cologne right they
think they're oh I don't smell anymore
so they keep spraying them and I'm
smelling really gross
so this happens with the research
assistants they keep thinking oh yeah it
doesn't smell bad anymore so they sprays
right there so I go I'll go down the lab
and back oh my god so we had to train
them to
to ignore the fact that they couldn't
smell anymore and so what you find is
that there is essentially no difference
in individuals ratings of these social
groups but you get a robust effect such
that on the days in which is a foul odor
in the room people are more harsh in
their valuations of gay men hi I have to
point out after we published the paper
we looked across all the times that we
had collected these data and we did find
a gender effect such that women in our
in our sample we're significantly more
likely to evaluate lesbian women it's
closer colder on the days in which there
was a smaller if you knew that point
that finding is there we just didn't get
to publish it because we didn't we
didn't see it in the data before before
we published it so this consistent again
with the idea that there is it is the
case that there is a specific effect of
disgust on things like at least we
predicted sexual behaviors and I'll give
you another another piece of evidence
that this actually might be the case oh
yeah a little stormy so this is a study
we did with Eric Houser one of the
things that I just said is that disgust
is specifically a motivation it's an
emotion that brings with it the
motivation to avoid disease but there
are other ways I've mentioned the
behavioural immune system in general so
the behavioral immune system is is this
again the set of motivations and
behaviors to keep us away from things
that might be contaminants he doesn't
have to be the emotion of disgust it
could be you could induce this
motivation some other way we were
interested in whether just reminding
people that disease was prevalent and
around might be enough to boost this
motivation to to make people wary of
disease now other people have studied
this this disease avoidance mechanism so
they've demonstrated that the threat of
disease is a particularly powerful
influencer on some kinds of social
judgments so you can compare you can
give people so these researchers at
university British Columbia
mark Schuyler in his group they'll
present individuals with say a demonstra
demonstration saying germs are looking
everywhere so they'll show you you know
like a like a kitchen sponge you know
and if you just if you google what
kitchen sponges the cesspool of bacteria
that they are you might be threatened as
well but they compared this importantly
with other kinds of threads so physical
threat so they'll tell you about the
statistics about accidents in the
workplace that might that might kill you
and disease threats seem to have a very
specific effect on cognition judgment
they've looked at evaluation of
immigrants and shown that disease
avoidance ramping up diseases vitamin
disease avoidance makes people more sort
of wary and negative in their judgments
of immigrants we the way that we did it
was simply remind people that the flu
was going around so this is when the flu
was at Cornell it wasn't hard it wasn't
difficult to convince people that they
ought to wash their hands or use hand
sanitizer to prevent the spread of the
flu so we'd bring people into the lab
and just remind them to sanitize their
hands and we asked individuals a number
of questions about moral actions so in
particular we asked moral actions that
might cause harm but weren't gross at
all and moral evaluations for for acts
that were gross but not harmful and
gross in a particular kind of way these
were sexual shows so odd sexual
practices I actually get nervous even
talking about it because I don't like
that I promise I didn't make these up
but I'll give you some examples so I
mean man is so a guy and his girlfriend
are house-sitting for his grandmother
and they have sex on the grandmothers
bed that one's not bad I a guy likes to
masturbate with a teddy bear
right so these are odd kind of odd
sexual practices but ever you know if
you expose people in so there's no harm
involved well it turns out that if you
remind people that there is disease and
environment asked them to wash their
hands at hand sanitize what you get is
that they show the selective negative
moral evaluation its ramped up but only
for these kinds of negative acts all
right so there is a selective effect
doesn't seem to affect moral judgments
like stealing ten dollars but it does
seem to affect judgments of these
officers reprises what we also found was
again these are modest effects but
simply reminding individuals to use say
hand sanitizer made them reported they
were more politically conservative so we
did this in a lab study originally I
didn't believe it we actually thought
something had gone wrong and so I said
let's do it again
we did in the lab again we got the fact
and so finally Eric tells her and I the
graduate student at the time I said okay
we got to do this a third time and here
the only thing we did was this as
students walked into the building this
is the building work that where the
psychology department is and there's a
big classroom on the ground floor a lot
of students are walking in all we did
was was place one of those Purell hand
sanitizer machines either all on one
side or on the other so I'm the left on
the right to counterbalance so nobody
could say that left and right had
anything to do with it
and we just had people fill out a
one-page questionnaire we said hey I'm
an undergrad RA I'm doing this for my
honors project can you just fill out
this this form over there by the hand
sanitizer or they would say over there
in that corner and when they filled it
out by the hand sanitizer they're
imported more conservative political
orientation as it Those it I the
reviewers were like really I said I
promise we did it three times and three
times we got it now again this is modest
and I do not have any notion that this
might let this even lasts five minutes
after the manipulation so I've I've
given this talk and people say you know
are Republicans going to do this
you know on the one hand III you never
know I mean maybe all you need is five
minutes and you know half a point on a
scale to get people to be more likely to
vote for a conservative policy certainly
affects a big fan where you know people
voting in schools versus churches are
more likely to vote in supportive
programs to support schools for instance
if they're in a school so it may be the
case but again it's modest the fact you
who knows how long it lasts all right
the last thing I'm going to tell you
about is work that we've been doing now
which is still in its initial stages and
we're collecting data as we speak what
we wanted was something kind of in
between the just pure correlational
experiments where we I mean
correlational studies where we ask
individuals to self-report the political
orientation and they're discussing Civet
II we wanted to get something closer to
disease avoidance but without
necessarily just bringing undergraduates
into the lab and so what we're looking
for was a natural incidence of disease
in the environment that we might be able
to correlate with some measure of social
attitudes turns out that a a friend
who's who also went to graduate school
here at Yale is our professor University
of Virginia Brian Nosek you all in bar
and I have been looking at implicit
attitudes toward homosexuality Brian
Nosek has been sort of in charge of this
for about eight years they've been
collecting across the country and across
the world attitudes toward toward a
variety of attitudes using this implicit
attitude test so they're they're sitting
on a ton of data what we can do is look
at Google Flu Trends so Google Flu
Trends is some point Google figured out
that when people get the flu they type
in flu symptoms into Google and they can
actually track better than the CDC at
least in at least more quickly
the spread of the flu across the country
across the world so we thought well if
disease threat is actually causing a
shift in judgments in the way that we
think perhaps in fact it might be
related to implicit attitudes for
homosexuality this is again like very
initial data and we haven't
haven't done any of the right controls
all this but we're doing it now
yeah we're and we're we're looking more
specifically now this is one of those we
call ambulance-chasing psychology the
ebola searches for ebola so for about
two months you've got this huge spike in
concern over Ebola in the US and then it
died down and now because we have
implicit attitudes toward a variety of
social groups we're gonna be able to
test whether or not in fact this this
threat of disease might have influenced
public attitudes at least implicit
attitudes and compare them to expose
deities okay I'll end it there by simply
saying for better for worse ah there is
this emotion that probably evolved to
protect us from germs the threat of
disease at least from putting poisons in
our mouths seems to have this influence
on something like who you vote for so
there are a whole bunch of things are
gonna influence any one of our moral
notions but the fact that that this
particular motion has the special
relationship to some of our moral
judgments is I used to just say as a
psychologist is interesting and keep it
at the descriptive level and say well
you know maybe if we can understand a
bit better how these moral notions are
shaped will at least be able to guard
against any bias I think that that I'm
I'm more comfortable now no not with a
question mark there but saying probably
not just this there are all kinds of
reasons to make moral judgments being
grossed out by something is probably not
the right one to shift your moral
judgments that is at the very least I
would want some additional reason so
every time I talk to my students about
this I say you know two very ugly people
having sex is gross but do you think
it's illegal there should be illegal or
do you think it's immoral and I'll say
well no that's silly well then
oh all I want to say is that what this
research can at least show us is that
maybe these emotions this particular
motion is in fact influence and why
people think something is immoral and I
think that it's the burden is on in two
people to defend why this relationship
if if they believe that it should hold
why I should hold so the the ethicist
Leon caste has actually argued that no
no look this is fine disgust does
influence our judgments our moral
judgments but it should right so he
famously argued and Pinker made the
psychologist even bigger made fun of him
for this but he argued look licking ice
cream cones in public is not only gross
but by dint of its being gross than it
should probably be outlawed so fine then
then I'm okay with that as long as we
make it explicit
hopefully this research can give us a
better understanding of you know how and
why our moral judgments are influenced
and why why in particular there's so
much disagreement in the world man so I
will end with thanking all of the
collaborators on this work and have a
few minutes for questions thank you
thank you any questions and we have a
few minutes quick one and so such a
newbie questions you probably already
have the paper on it but talk about
vulnerability driving conservativism so
does inoculation Drive liberalism so if
we just do pre-imposed vaccine and make
them wash their hands and give them an
airborne you can run this study that's a
very good question and I don't so I
don't have data on it but there is a
student at Duke University who we're
supposed to be getting data on this we
plan on getting it on it we don't have
it yet
I don't know in fact you point to
something interesting which is I don't
know what somebody waiting for
inoculation is what the psychological
process there is it might be that they
are extra threatened by disease right
before it might be there right after
they're feeling extra so the the study
that we were that we hope to run
actually is something like we didn't
want to start with inoculation because
of the complications but yes giving them
like a drink the same drink that we tell
them is like one of these immune
boosters versus I am it's an energy
drink and seeing if if they feel extra
protected or invulnerable that they
might actually realize that's great no I
don't it's not a newbie question it's
something that I wish had taken me only
45 minutes to think of but it took me 10
years yeah right side
and on the other hand you find and all
your experiments that it can be pushed
around willy-nilly by like whether
there's an intended measure yeah there
are of course long term trends in
attitudes toward some of these social
things now and there are long term
trends like not not like over the course
of the flu season but over the course of
hundreds of years or more there's long
term trends and changes to threats or
disability yeah so so yeah all right
I'll try to answer the question there
there is great work on historical
presence of pathogens in certain
environments and so what they've argued
is so here's the pest here's the
pessimism what these researchers have
argued is when you look at our best
estimates of not current diseases of not
current pathogens in an environment by
historical presence of pathogens in
particular geographical region Thursday
that the cultures that emerged in
regions in which there were high degrees
of pathogens are more conservative there
especially sexually conservative but
they're also more wary of foreigners and
so there is that evidence that so over
the long term you have mechanism working
and such that because cultures are
obviously adaptations in many ways to
even physical environments that this
would be the case on the other hand I
want to be more optimistic and say well
obviously you know our attitudes 100
years ago we're so much worse than they
are now that this is why I always point
out to the modest these the modest
effects here so I think that what what
we hopefully will find is that there are
so many things that are influencing our
attitudes in these in this domain that
that just like I think to very
unattractive people who are having sex
is disgusting maybe to me but that it
shouldn't be immoral that we can start
we can tease tease that apart in many
ways I think my plea at the end to
separate the two or to at least make
note of what the influences on our
attitudes are is something that people
actually do so I think that people now
say you know what it is the case
specially they will say it is the case
that I may be disgusted by certain
things but it ought not influence any of
my dozens and you know we're creatures
who can reason we can do calculus for
God's sakes I'm not willing to say that
that we are nothing but let you know
leaps blowing in the wind influenced by
environmental primes but rather that we
can actually as Paul has argued there's
such a thing as moral progress now meta
ethically I don't know what ground he
stands on but but I do fundamentally
believe it
why are you twisted ah no you know it's
the world's most convoluted supervillain
you should using social psychology
findings to do I think this might work
let me do a hundred years of research on
you know I you know I'm willing to take
that risk curing disease with the you
know the slight risk that it will
influence people's but but your point is
taken you know I I just don't know
further research funded whenever we
bother to look it seems as if and this
is post talk but it seems it seems as if
there is this loose sort of sexual
reproductive domain that is especially
especially influenced by by disgust and
so we found gay marriage abortion in
some cases stem cell research and human
cloning those are the ones that we
actually have evidence for and again
completely post talk it seems as if
there is something about this
reproductive domain that that might be
special but you know again we're trying
right now we're trying to see what what
the specificity really is like what we
need to ask more yeah more rain rich
people construct Thomas Brown being
complicit the most words the subject
would probably get any construction one
favoring around it they should stay a
moraine right according to what they
feel but this data computer would all
see other way around we first have
I deal with them and use the discussed
motive type of personal the Nazi
propaganda to propagate your own brain
where does one ramp there's a lot of
question but what way the Spanky
brothers notice we were fighting one way
the facility goes yeah I saw this might
be a boring answer but I most certainly
think it goes both ways so it one of the
reasons that I find it has to be
interesting is because how easily you
can tag something to it so it might be
that I can get you to feel disgust
pretty quickly and easily about
something unrelated like a smell and
that this makes a particularly effective
at tagging with a social group but it
also is the case that you can make
people have certain beliefs about social
groups that might give rise to emotions
and I think that that the right question
is to go back to Aristotle is that it's
it's silly to I say silly but you know
I've made there before it's a lump
emotions altogether and I think each
emotion will be different some emotions
are highly appraisal heavy so anger
really really matters if I think Paul
slighted me I get angry and once if I
find out that I was wrong you know I
might have some leering physiological
effects of the anger but I should at
least no longer have the appraisal that
causes anger and so I'm like oh I was
wrong you know he didn't steal the $10 I
thought he did on the other hand some
emotions are fairly non-cognitive
disgust I think is one of them it could
be that something like empathy is fairly
non cognitive as well and so you would
expect that in these cases you can have
the causality go the other way so I
think there should be a question that
has asked the emotion by emotion yes
the effect of the trade of openness to
experience yeah this is openness to
experience is one of is in terms of
individual differences like personality
measures in openness to experience is
probably the one that's most associated
with liberal conservative as you might
expect I'm you know it's almost by
definition that a conservative is going
to be less open tricks to to novelty
openness to experience is mildly related
to discuss Institute is there is a
modest correlation so there's a
collection of responses anxiety disgusts
and this trait openness to experience
that are all that all seem related to
each other but even when you
statistically control for openness to
experience the effect of disgust on
conservatism is still there but the
primers might be different if you're
seeing a photo
Brian yours is a Brazilian versus being
served at Connecticut State Fair yeah
there's a good question I actually think
that one of the reasons what one of the
reasons that I'm have been doing work on
this person or morality is I think that
the right unit of analysis for moral
judgments are as people so I think that
it's a little bit ABS it's it's moving
toward the abstract to say that you know
we'll have a bunch of facts that we
think of as right or wrong so I you
probably can get discussed to Jessica
we've shown that you can get discussed
and just influence our moral judgments
about specific acts I think the most
powerful effects are gonna be about
people so you know when we look at the
disgust sensitivity scale has subscales
so there's discussed at a low level
stuff like food that might make you
gross out but there is one that's about
interpersonal contamination so you sip a
stranger's soda by mistake right so the
the
rats of contamination from other people
is what we get the biggest effects for
so I think that people are a big threat
and I think that you're gonna get even
just describing a person who does the
rock like a grouse or wrong thing you'll
get better bigger effects than just
asking like this rule I mean you know
the day you know we write we write
gossip you know we sell magazines in the
grocery impulse aisle that say like you
know Kanye West cheats on Kim Kardashian
they don't say adultery right or wrong
right we care about people and people
like I think is the right unit of
analysis and I think that they action
they're deeply reflective and they
reason well I really shouldn't feel this
way and they argue it so if you look at
a person what their emotions do over
their course they'll likely be very
depressed and the other thing that it's
hard to see with experimental data is
the context that people seek out because
they want to have a particular kind of
emotion right so liberals and
conservatives have political rallies
what do political rallies do they don't
tell you what the party stand or they
generate these emotions right so that's
kind of I just wonder so how your theory
takes a counselor people's ability to
actually change their emotional reaction
choose a context to facilitate which
regular motion maybe think desire but
don't have yeah so first of all kind of
you to call this a theory but I I think
that you're right and in fact what a lab
manipulation by design does is stripped
context away and and what you you miss
out on that
so Paul bloom and I wrote a brief little
piece when I was a grad school that was
a reaction to to this very influential
article by the psychologist Jonathan
Hite saying that you know it's all just
emotions and post hoc reasoning is what
and one of the things we argued is that
this isn't taking into account that we
can shape our emotional reactions I
think this is this is just true that you
might actually if you are slightly
sensitized to say the plight of African
Americans in United States then you
might actually take a seminar on racial
inequality and this might actually make
you extra likely to feel a certain kind
of emotions maybe anger at injustice or
empathy of the suffering and in that
this way we shape our own emotions to
what extent we're very good at this I
don't know and to what extent we're good
at talking about this it's it's not
clear like it it's you know I might
think that in fact I am very sensitive
to this and you know you bring you into
the lab and actually I'm not but but I
think that you're you're asking the
right set of questions
you